quand tu as la nourriture qui diminue et
tu as presque plus d'eau tout le reste
devient vraiment du superflux la seule
chose que tu veux c'est boire salut
bienvenue dans ce nouvel interview à la
table aujourd'hui je vais recevoir Rémy
Camu c'est un aventurier c'est un
explorateur mais surtout c'est quelqu'un
comme vous et moi à la base il était
maître d'hôtel dans un restaurant étoilé
à Genève comment on passe de ça à
traverser l'Australie 5400 km en courant
ça il va vous le raconter merci d'avance
pour sa générosité si vous voulez
écouter les versions audio de ces
podcasts ça existe le podcast s'appelle
interview à la table l'épisode avec
reméy Camu que vous allez regarder sera
disponible un petit peu en décalé le 16
octobre sur toutes les plateformes de
podcast je vais maintenant pouvoir aller
fouiller dans la tête et savoir ce qu' a
pensé et ressenti celui qui a tiré une
charrette de 40 kg pendant 5400 km qui a
qui a mangé du kangourou mort qui a bu
du liquide qui sortait de lui-même
vraiment qui a vécu l'extrême reméy si
je comprends bien tu es la personne à
suivre demain en cas d'attaque zombie
est-ce que j'ai résumé toute ta vie
c'est relativement
rapide je sais pas si sur les zombies
mais peut-être ouais est-ce que tu as
pas développé ce talent- làà de
s'adapter très vite et de comprendre
très vite son environnement si ça c'est
quelque chose que j'ai appris par le
temps effectivement à travers mes
aventures et puis le travail c'est ce
que j'ai appris au quotidien c'est quoi
aujourd'hui le plus important quand tu
veux vivre des aventures comme celles
que tu as pu vivre pour moi c'est la
préparation et c'est ce que je dis
souvent à à des stagiaires ou à des
personnes c'est tellement plus simple de
résoudre une problème quand on est assis
sur son fauteuil avec une petite bière à
la main et que de se retrouver en plein
milieu je sais pas en Afrique et de se
dire merde j'ais peut-être plus l'éviter
ça parce que si j'avais bien préparé on
en serait pas là donc ce que tu mets
derrière préparation c'est recherche de
connaissance et et imaginer tous les
problèmes possibles pour déjà y
répondreo ex c'est ça vraiment tout tout
envisager de tout ton projet et ça peut
prendre quelques quelques jours ça peut
prendre même quelques minutes tu pars
faire une randonnée avec des potes le
fait d'acheter une carte hygiène et de
regarder le tracé ah oui il y a un peu
dénivelé ici là il y a une petite maison
peut s'arrêter il y a un petit point
d'eau bah ça s'appelle une préparation
même si elle est pas très longue ça
reste une préparation si tu peux pas
éviter les problèmes tu peux anticiper
sur comment je vais réagir sur les
problèmes qui pe moi ça m'est arrivé en
Asie sur le sur le Mékong pour passer
des des endroits très très risqués avec
des gros rapides des gros volumes je
suis tout seul ok si je me lance si je
me mets sur la droite là il y a un
siphon ça fait comme ça
l'eau va me repousser de ce côté-là ok
là j'ai une petite chance d'y arriver si
je passe ici voilà ce qui peut se passer
si je passe là voilà et cetera si
malheureusement j'ai une problématique
il y a les villageois qui sont là il y
en a pas un seul qui va sauter à l'eau
pour venir me chercher parce qu'ils
savent pas nager donc ça peut être
problématique et à chaque fois je me
pose toutes ces questions et après je me
lance aujourd'hui tu es un inventurier
confirmé avant ça tu étais maître
d'hôtel qui est un aventurier confirmé
ce qui est c'est vrai qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé est-ce que il y a eu un
événement est-ce qu' il y a eu un déclic
comment on passe de maître d'hôtel à ce
que tu es devenu un aventurier confirmé
j'ai toujours vécu en pleine campagne
vraiment au milieu de Nuart et je
passais plus de temps dans la forêt que
en pleine ville et j'avais vraiment
l'impression que la ville était un
environnement très hostile pour moi
alors que je me sentais bien dans ma
forêt j'aimais bien passer du temps
quand j'avais 8 9 10 ans dans la forêt
donc ça ça a toujours été en moi et puis
on ser on se fait rattraper par le monde
du travail j'aimais beaucoup la
restauration parce que j'aimais beaucoup
le contact avec les gens le respect les
valeurs de la restauration vraiment
quelque chose
presque militaire et j'aimais beaucoup
ce cadre là puis en
2010 j'ai lu un livre d'un d'un mec qui
a traversé l'Amérique en courant et
c'est comme ça que je me suis dit si lui
il l'a fait je vois pas pourquoi j'y
arriverai pas je vais partir et je vais
traverser un pays en courant c'est un
humain qui l'a fait je suis un humain je
peut le faire c'est exactement ça je me
suis dis il il a pas plus de compétences
qu'un autre il a pas c'est pas un
surhomme Superman n'existe pas tout le
monde a des capacités tout le monde est
capable de sortir de sa zone de confort
il faut juste se donner les moyens avoir
une vraie discipline et on y arrive donc
donc c'est ce que je me suis dit on va
le faire c'était Jamel bal exactement et
en fait ce que je voulais vivre c'était
pas son aventure j'allais dire de course
à pied parce que pour moi c'était un
moyen de transport qui était c'était le
slow travel c'est on prend vraiment le
temps d'aller voir les choses et ce que
j'adorais dans son livre et bien c'était
plus sur les rencontres le partage tout
ce qu'il avait autour de de ces de son
aventure pouvoir aller à la rencontre
des gens différemment et et pouvoir
m'imprégner ben de leur culture est-ce
que toi tu rêvais d'être explorateur
d'être aventureur non je rêvais pas de
d'exploration je rêvais de
pouvoir continuer à vivre de cette de ce
mode de vie que j'avais quand j'étais
gamin d'être vraiment au contact de la
nature dans ma forêt et et c'est c'est
ce qui a fait que j'ai poursuivi en tout
cas dans les aventures après avoir le lu
le livre de Jamel bal c'est c'est c'est
quoi la première chose que tu fais je
finis le livre un matin je fais nuit
blanche on est en Bretagne on est dans
un tout petit village j'étais parti en
vacances avec ma maman et on avait j'ai
acheté le livre sur une brocante et je
suis rentré dans cette petite maison
qu'on avait qu'on avait pris en location
elle était blanche avec des petits
volets bleus et puis je passe la soirée
sur dans dans le lit en train de lire le
livre et le lendemain quand je
redescends ma mère était sur la petite
table ronde en robe de chambre en train
de prendre un grand bol avec un café tu
as bien dormi je fais j'ai pas dormi
encore elle m dit bon qu'est-ce que tu
as fait j'ai lu le livre là toute la
nuit un truc de dingue et tu sais quoi
je viens d'avoir une idée maman moi
aussi je vais traverser un pays en
courant ma mère me regarde elle me dit
bah déjà commence déjà par pr ton café
on verra plus tard et ça a été vraiment
le début du truc je suis revenu avec ça
je me suis dit mais en fait je vais
vraiment le faire je vais me donner les
moyens de mettre les choses en place et
donc j'ai commencé d'abord à acheter une
carte parce qu'il me fallait le parcours
qu'est-ce que je vais faire et c'était
quoi le but derrière tout ça et je
voulais vraiment pour moi c'est c'est ce
qui prime sur une aventure c'est le
l'objectif le but s'il y a pas
d'objectif il y a pas de but c'est juste
bah je pars pour faire un défis pour moi
il y avait aucun intérêt et je voulais
vraiment aller rencontrer les aborigènes
et je voulais les rencontrer les vrais
Abor Origène très loin dans les
communautés qui sont plus en lien avec
la terre et c'est ce que je voulais
faire et j'ai dit je vais le faire en
courant pour aller à leur rencontre un
moyen de locomotion qu'ils avaient
peut-être pour certains leur ancêtres et
cetera quoi il c'est combien de
kilomètres au total là ça fait 5400
bornes de Melbourne à Darwin avec un
avec un petit détour pour aller voir les
aborigènes donc les deux communautés
kaltukajjara et mutijulu donc les deux
communautés qui sont perdu au milieu du
désert et qui parlent le même langage ah
ok qui parl le c'est intéressant le
pitajara ce qui m'a permis d'apprendre
quelques mots dans une communauté pour
pouvoir les bien sûrréer du contact
encore plus facilement parce que c'est
très je crois que c'est la partie la
plus difficile lorsqu'on vait dans on va
dans des endroits très reculés c'est la
communication mais là tu ressens
vraiment cette barrière de la langue de
pas pouvoir t'exprimer correctement de
dire tes envies ce que tu ressens et
cetera et ça c'est difficile je trouve
que c'est très compliqué quand tu te
retrouves avec des gens qui vivent dans
un autre mode de vie un autre cadre de
vie et toi tu dois essayer de leur
expliquer bien que tu fais ça en courant
pour les rencontrer et cetera et que tu
voudrais apprendre deux ça c'est dur tu
es en Australie que tu vas faire en
courant tu étais déjà coureur tu étais
déjà Mar marathonien j'étais serveur
voilà donc tu faisais beaucoup de SP
durant le service c'est la même chose
non j'étais pas du tout marathonien je
je courais vraiment pour le plaisir des
5 5 10 km comme ça de temps en temps
mais il y avait aucune course à pied
j'ai dû mettre une discipline de me dire
il va falloir aller courir l'armi il va
falloir mettre des baskets et tous les
jours aller courir pour t'entraîner pour
faire ce projet donc ça a été euh
vraiment cette discipline c'était le la
la base de du projet c'était de me de de
de mixer entre la restauration et
l'entraînement pour être prêt pour ce
défi oui parce que tu n'abandonnes pas
ton travail du jour au lendemain non
plus non puis financièrement il te faut
quand même une ressource financière pour
continuer de vivre donc tu tu peux pas
dire euh j'arrête tout et je vais vivre
de l'aventure surtout quand tu tu n'as
aucun nom tu es personne il faut trouver
les ressources pour pouvoir et continuer
au quotidien mais te préparer pour tes
défis tu as essayé de démarcher un petit
peu en sponsor
même pas c'est quoi les réponses qu'on
te faisait la plupart du temps c'est on
vous rappellera monsieur Camu et et je
me dis en réfléchissant je me dis que
c'est complètement logique tu as un
gamin qui arrive qui a 25 ans et qui te
dit je vais faire ça en courant pas de
véhicule d'assistance en totale
autonomie je vais tirer une remorque qui
va faire 40 kg avec toute ma nourriture
et mon eau et je serai en plein désert
vous faites des marathons non non je
j'ai jamais couru je je suis serveur je
suis maître d'hôtel dans la restauration
d'accord on vous rappellera monsieur
Camu et en fait je pense qu'il voulait
pour eux c'était logique de pas financer
bah les funérailles d'une personne qui
part c'est ça c'est ça je pense que
c'était c'était pas pour pour perdre de
l'argent ou pas en perdre c'était de se
dire je participe pas ce suicide organis
c'est ça ah d'accord donc on va enterrer
quelqu'un en Australie on paye pour ça
c'est cool c'est génial et effectivement
au retour j'ai des gens à qui j'avais
que j'avais déjà contacté qui m'ont
rappelé par la suite et qui m'ont dit
mais vous l'avez vraiment fait ah oui je
vous ai dit que j'allais trava je oui je
le fait oui bien sûr que je l'ai fait
quand quand je regarde ton histoire ton
aventure elle a commencé à partir de ce
moment-l en fait elle a commencé sur ce
terrain préparatoire complètement mais
toutes les aventures pour moi commencent
sur la partie de préparation et c'est
une une vraie difficulté à expliquer aux
gens qui te suiv par exemple sur les
réseaux et je leur dis vous vous ne
voyez uniquement que la phase de
réalisation mais l'aventure elle a déjà
commencé un an 2 ans 3 ans plusutôt
parce que rien que de poser une feuille
de papier blanche avec un crayon dire ok
je vais faire ça bah c'est le début de
l'aventure il faut tout organiser
trouver le staff trouver les personnes
qui vont travailler autour de du du
projet le marketing la communication
préparation physique préparation mentale
euh la faune la flore le parcours et
cetera et cetera tu avais déjà des
notions de survie ou pas du tout avant
de partir en Australie
zéro j'ai tout appris euh j'ai appris
j'ai appris quelques trucs sur les
livres et après ça m'a euh ça m'a un peu
embêté de juste lire des livres et je me
suis retrouvé confronté directement à
mes propres peurs en plein milieu du
bouche australien donc j'ai appris à mes
dépend ce que je dis aux gens c'est que
faut être pragmatique et opportuniste et
c'est ce que je leur dis à chaque fois
et avec un petit peu de créativité et je
vous assure que quand on est contraint
quand on a des choses en moins et bien
la créativité devient de plus en plus
importante donc je vous assure avec rien
on arrive à créer des trucs
extraordinaires au milieu de N part donc
tu es lancé dans le désert australien
euh tu as une remorque ouais que tu
construite construite par mon papa il y
avait quoi dedans il y avait de la
nourriture il y avait de l'eau j' avais
une autre paire de basket un appareil
photo un ordinateur disque dur panneau
solaire batterie tampon de quoi réparer
un peu la remorque des médicaments que
j'ai balancé très rapidement parce qu'en
fait il y a pas besoin d'avoir 15000
médicaments il faut juste avoir un truc
pour le mal de vendre quand tu manges
des trucs dégueulasses ouais et puis
juste un peu de btadine pour te soigner
les PL vite fait et c'est tout c'est
assez rustique ouais c'était
principalement l'eau et la nourriture
qui était indispensable en PAsie du
désert mais ça restait une remorque à
tirer qui faisait une quarantaine de K
couchage ouais sac de couchage matelas
de sol le bas de la pyramide de Melow la
fine couche voilà c'est vraiment le
strict min minum et malgré tout ça ça
faisait une quarantaine de kilos ouais
mais parce que mon père était quelqu'un
de la campagne et quand il m'a dit je
vais construire ta remorque il avait
omis de expliquer qu'il avait construire
un char d'assaut donc la remorque pesait
une dizaine de kilos à tiré à vide et je
lui dis mais papa tu sais que faut que
je la charge elle me dit bon e ça va
tenir c'est bon tu peux y aller et elle
a elle a cassé au bout d'un jour c'est
vrai ouais du coup c'est au moins c'est
arrivé très vite ma fois très vite aussi
tu as dû être confronté à la chaleur et
à la douleur physique ouais c'était
assez rapide mais le fait de passer par
le sud pour regagner le Nord h et bien
j'ai eu une période d'acclimatation qui
était plutôt favorable parce qu'on passe
sur un climat continental puis
rapidement méditérranéen et ensuite
semi-désertique et c'est ce que
j'explique moi à mes stagiaires lors les
stages de survie je leur dis vous savez
l'être humain est capable de faire tout
et n'importe quoi vous pouvez lui faire
subir tout ce que vous voulez la seule
difficulté qu'il a c'est qu'il a besoin
de temps pour s'adapter aux choses si
vous mettez quelqu'un rapidement qui qui
vit en plein désert vous le mettez tout
de suite sur la banquise à mon avis il
va pas faire longtemps si vous lui
laissez le temps de s'adapter vous
verrez il serait capable de faire de
grandes choses et quand j'étais en plein
milieu du désert il y a des gens qui
passaient en voiture qui faisaient
demi-tour qui revenait à mes côtés on
vient de passer et en fait c'est ma
femme qui m'a dit au bout d'un kilomètre
tu as vu il y avait un mec qui courait
j'ai fait demi-tour et là on est en
train de se dire nous on est dans la
voiture avec la clim et il fait super
chaud et on en peut plus et toi tu es
dehors en train de courir et ça va je
dis ça va mais je lui parlais tu sais en
piétinant comme ça et me dit mais
pourquoi tu piétine je sais parce que si
je m'arrête non c'est que la route était
tellement chaude ça faisait fondre la
les chaussures et doncit ah d'accord ok
j'avais pas compris pourquoi donc
c'était impressionnant lui il était dans
la voiture avec la clim et moi j'étais
de avec ma casquette et non ça va et
tout fait mais fait combien je bah il
fait à peu près 50 là on est bien là
est-ce que tu témoignais tous les jours
en te déchargeant sur ton ordi ou caméra
ou dictapone ou est-ce que juste tu
vivais ça t'introspecter c'est tout non
j'avais les deux enfin les deux non les
trois même j'avais un dictaphone où je
parlais des fois je le posais et pendant
que je montais mon encampement en fait
je je parlais pas forcément au
dictaphone mais je parlais à moi-même
comme ça ça je trouvais ça très marrant
euh on parle to on cite souvent le film
avec Tom Hanks seul au monde où il parle
à un ballon et bien j'avais la même le
même ressenti avec ma remorque si tu
veux ma remorque était
un binô quoi et je lui parlais je
l'insultais quand ça montait parce que
elle était trop lourde je l'insultais
quand ça descendait parce que poussait
au cul euh des fois quand j'avais de la
FL heureusement que tu étais là parce
qu'on a pu transporter toute cette eau
donc j'avais vraiment une vraie
complicité avec et de temps en temps
j'aimais bien aussi écrire je racontais
toutes toutes mes petites galères et je
notais les des des éléments importants
combien de lites d'eau je consommais par
jour combien d'heures j'avais couru et
combien de kilomètres et jeess j'essayis
d'avoir un petit un petit carnet de
route comme ça ça et après il y avait
les caméras dans lesqueles tu peux
t'exprimer aussi différemment et après
il y avait des des moments de de de vie
où je faisais rien du tout si tu veux je
me je me souviens plein de fois où je me
posais dans le désert et en plein soleil
et tu fermes les yeux et tu tu ressens
le sable chaud c'est qui vient de
fouetter le visage les grains de sable
tu as cette odeur particulière avec un
peu d'eucalyptus dans le bouche
australien des fois tuas tu sens des
fois des animaux morts qui sont à
proximité et tu fais vraiment qu'un et
tu as vraiment cette sensation de flow
et de dire en fait même si je suis très
sale j'ai pas beaucoup à manger j'ai pas
beaucoup à boire il y a pas un seul
endroit où sur terre où je voudrais être
je veux être que ici et je suis trop
bien là je me souviens dans le livre
quand tu as écrit que tu as mangé bu
sang d'un kangourou c'était vital j'ai
pas dit que c'était forcément bon sur
sur l'instant T mais c'était vital
j'avais besoin qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pour en arriver là en tout cas com
j'avais de moins en moins de de
nourriture dans dans ma remorque et il
fallait trouver quelque chose qui me
permette de pouvoir tenir encore un peu
plus longtemps quand tu te retrouves en
plein au milieu du bouche australien les
distances lorsqu'on quitte les côtes
deviennent de plus en plus longues pour
avoir des points de chute soit sur de
l'eau à consommer soit de la nourriture
donc à chaque fois qu'on trouve quelque
chose sur le parcours et bien vaut mieux
le voir comme une opportunité exactement
être pragmatique opportuniste ça passe à
ce moment-là on récupère le kangourou
c'était le matin et il faut que je
trouve à manger j'ai faim il faut que je
trouve à manger il faut que je trouve
quelque chose à manger rapidement et à
boire pour avoir de l'eau suffisamment
en quantité et puis avoir des nutriments
et et le camion est arrivé le kangour
était sur le bas côté le camion est
arrivé et là tu dis c'est marrant ils
ont une route convergente et c'est
marrant on a
l'impression ch il devrait y avoir un
truc super sympa qui va se passer devant
moi et effectivement en Australie les
les routiers adorent éclater tout ce qu'
a sur la route ouais c'est un kiff voil
ils ont des parbuff pour ça et dès que
ça traverse il les éclate et là le
kangourou tape le devant du du camion
fait un salto ouvrier et tombe sur le
bas côté il était 9h du matin je suis
bah voilà j'ai eu ma réponse j'ai à
manger et dans la logique je sais que
j'ai à boire dedans parce que il y a y a
le sang du kangourou je vais pouvoir
consommer directement après il faut
passer out le fait que bien
effectivement l'animal vient juste
d'être mort il faut le dépesser et c'est
ce que j'ai toujours trouvé très
étonnant avec l'Australie c'est que tu
fais ça en France tu es en pleine
campagne et tuas un mec en vélo qui
s'arrête pour dépesser un chevreuil bon
j'appelle les flics tu vois et je me dis
il est pas bien là alors qu'en Australie
voiture il passé il faisit coucou puis
il dit bonjour et on le voit dans une
vidéo TikTok ça tu tu as partagé on les
voit vraim on dirait qu'il te font bon
courage quoi vas-y Go éta es en train de
manger mec qui bonjour bah bonjour Voilà
et tu dis c'est un truc de dingue j'ai
du sang de kangourou partout sur moi je
suis à quatre pattes en train de manger
un kangourou sur le bord de la route les
gens passent et pour eux c'est normal
c'est ok ça c'est fou toi tu l'as
dépissé tu dis mais comment on apprend à
dépesser comment c'est as regarder un
petit tuto sur Youtube je
dépesse un kangourou non la restauration
m'a beaucoup aidé sur certains points
parce que j'ai fait cuisine aussi dans
la restauration et puis et puis après
bon vit à la campagne quand ENF j'ai
grandi à la campagne donc aller à la à
la chasse dépesser des lapins c'est des
choses que on faisait régulièrement je
te je te dis pas que je que j'ai dépessé
l' animal correctement pour vraiment
garder la peau et cetera le but c'était
d'aller vite de me nourrir voilà c'était
vraiment bénéficier en plus de un animal
quoi qu'il arrive il serait mort et et
comme ça s'est passé devant toi tu es
sûr de la fraîcheur aussi de l'animal
parce que il y a ça aussi avec cette
chaleur et toi c'est un truc qu'on a
qu'on m'a reproché de il y en a qui
m'ont dit mais pourquoi est-ce que tu as
tué un kangourou j'ai il n'a pas été tué
j'été opportuniste il a été tapé par un
camion ex vraiment tu avais assez de
vivre ou c'était que ça que des
questions d'opportunités tu gardais un
peu de vivre au cas où les opportunités
se présentent pas tu l'as envisagé tuas
tuas en fait tu as les deux et puis faut
savoir que dans le bouche australien tu
as quand même des superettes c'est ce
qui s'appelle les Road house ok donc
c'est un mix entre une station service
un peu de nourriture des fois tu as une
petite base de camping c'est vraiment
une petite base de vie au Milie n part
mais ell sont éloigné de 300 400 km pour
certains certaines pardon mais après je
faisais également du prélèvement de ce
que je trouvais dans la nature c'était
soit des lézards des serpents des
kangourous et cetera d'être opportuniste
et de me dire bah je préserve ce que
j'ai dans ma remorque et puis j'avance
et au moins j'ai de quoi me nourrir
parce que j'ai fait du prélèvement dans
la nature il y a aussi le la la la faune
qui t'entour là on parle de kangourou et
cetera euh qui peuvent d'ailleurs être
dangereux mais il y a encore plus
dangereux que ça il y a les serpents les
plus dangereux qui sont en Australie
ouais comment ça tu l'as géré comment
est-ce que c'était une peur inconsciente
une vigilance est ce que tu avancé tu
disais tant que je vois rien de spécial
ben c'est qu'il y a rien l'avantage du
du du serpent c'est que les tris quart
du temps ils ont une ils sont capables
de ressentir les vibrations de vraiment
de et ils sont déjà partis alors que tu
as même pas encore aperçu le serpent
quand tu tombes dessus c'est parce que
soit il a été surpris tout comme j'ai pu
lettre et cetera et là à ce moment-là il
y a confrontation soit benah je le
laisse partir parce que ben j'en ai pas
besoin soit du coup je j'essaie de
l'attraper pour le manger c'est ce que
j'ai fait ce qui s'est passé une fois
avec une espèce extrêmement danguse avec
un Brown Snake voilà donc tu te
retrouves à devoir tu ok faut peser le
pour et le contre si je fais ça voilà ce
qui se passe si je fais ça voilà ce qui
se passe mais si je me fais mordre et
que c'est pas une morsure blanche donc
il m'injecte vraiment sa quantité de
venin nécessaire si je prends le
téléphone satellite en espérant que la
couverture nuageuse ne soit pas là et
que j'arrive à capter quelque chose que
je contae les secours combien de temps
ils vont mettre pour venir c'est à peu
près 1 he et3 2h à peu près le temps de
vie que tu pouvait avoir donc il faut
vraiment être très vigilant et pas de se
dire je le prends à pleine main et après
je trouve la solution donc ça a été
toujours voilà de des petites mises en
garde envers moi me dire fais très
attention parce que il peut il peut
t'enlever la vie donc c'est pas après
coup que tu as compris que wouh j'ai eu
de la chance ça aurait pu être fatal
c'est déjà là aussi je je je savais que
ça pouvait être dangereux mais après
l'adress adrénaline te fait j'is dire
presque oublier tout le reste parce que
tu sais que tu vas avoir tu sais que tu
peux être mordu tu peux tu sais que tu
peux y laisser la vie mais tu as
tellement besoin de boire tu as
tellement besoin de manger tuoublies un
peu cet aspect là la peur est présente
et il faut la gérer mais tu sais que tu
as pas il faut que tu l'attrapes il faut
que tu manges donc tu lui coupes la tête
tu le manges je coupe la tête j'enterre
la tête parce que il y a toujours les
glandes et ah oui imagine imagine tu as
un mec avec sa nada il sont en train de
rouler tu vois il faut que je m'arrête
pisser il s'arrête il garde la voiture
il sort de la voiture il est pied nu il
met il met le pied sur la tête du le
truc vraiment débile au milieu de nu
part terminé donc tu enterres la tête et
ensuite moi j'ai fait un feu et ensuite
tu tu retires le feu tu creuses tu en
mets le serpent sous le sable tu remets
le sable et tu remets le le feu
par-dessus et tu cuis le serpent à
l'étouffé ok voilà OK et c'est après en
le mangeant où tu t'es dit j'ai quand
même voilà c'est là où je où j'ai
réalisé ce que ce que je venais de faire
de tuer un serpent de le P pour le
manger et cetera est-ce queil y a un
moment où tu t'es dit là je vais pas
m'en sortir alors je l'ai peut-être pas
formulé comme ça je je m'en souviendrais
je m'en souviens pas forcément mais il y
a eu un moment où je me suis retrouvé
sans eau pendant 4 jours et en fait tu
te rends vraiment compte des besoins
primaire de l'être humain le soir après
une bonne journée tu te dis franchement
une bonne douche ça ferait du bien et
puis une fois que tu as passé cette
étape là de dormir comme ça dans le
désert des fois avec des environs pas
forcément agréable tu te dis j'aimerais
bien un bon lit quelque chose de très
cosi ou j'arrive à me reposer et puis
plus ça avance c'est quand tu as réserve
de nourriture et d'eau commence à Nour à
diminuer au début tu penses un peu à la
nourriture ça serait bien un bon petit
truc avec avec un goût particulier un
peu sucré tu rêves de ça moi je passais
des heures à courir des fois je pensais
à un steak fais oh qu'est-ce que ça doit
être bon truc bien grillé et tout et tu
penses qu'à ça et quand tu as la
nourriture qui dimue et l'eau qui
s'accompagne et et que tu as presque
plus d'eau tout le reste devient
vraiment du superflux la seule chose que
tu veux c'est boire et on revient
vraiment sur une base très Prim juste de
l'eau de parce que le corps humain est
composé c'est la survie avec un Grand T
là voilà et là tu dis je veux boire et
je ferai n'importe quoi pour boire donc
au début tu te dis bah je vais me
rationner à un moment donné je vais
commencer à trouver d'autres stratégies
pour trouver de l'eau et tu as vraiment
ce ce truc très primaire très animal qui
qui qui revient en fait et donc au bout
de 4 jours sans sans boire j'ai eu un
petit moment de lucidité à un moment
donné j'ai posé mon mon trépied avec mon
appareil photo et j'ai pris une photo je
me dis voilà cette photolà je la garde
si je viens à crever et bien les gens
qui me retrouveront ils veront mon
appareil photo ils allumeront et ils
verront la dernière photo et la dernière
photo c'est un mec souriant et qui kiffe
son aventure et puis si bah je suis
aujourd'hui en train de parler devant un
micro devant Fabien et bien je me dis
que la photo que je garderait et bien ça
serait un bon souvenir de me dire
qu'est-ce que j'étaé con ce moment-là
j'aurais pu faire différemment et cetera
et donc j'ai pris cette photo et après
je me suis posé la question qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour trouver de l'eau j'étais
à côté d'une Crick à sécher et là c'est
toujours l'effort que tu vas fournir
est-ce qu'il est gratifiant à un moment
donné et ça c'est super important et
c'est une notion que j'essaie
d'enseigner à des enfants dans les dans
les écoles en conférences ou même dans
les stages de survie je leur dis si vous
faites quelque chose que ça vous coûte
du temps et de l'énergie et que c'est
pas payant arrêter ça sert à rien de le
faire et c'est ce qui exactement ce qui
s'est passé je me suis retrouvé dans le
bouche dans cette Crick ass séché et
j'ai commencé à creuser et j'ai dû
creuser peut-être je sais pas 50 cm et
j'ai arrêté je fais non mais attends là
tu es en train de faire une connerie tu
es en train de creuser tu sais pas s'il
y a de l'eau tu es en train de t'épuiser
et le peu que je vais trouver ça va
juste me permettre de combler ce que tu
as dépens ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
dépensé et donc où est-ce qu'il y a un
liquide que je peux consommer facilement
et qui va pas me nécessiter une grosse
grosse quantité d'énergie pour le
produire et là je dis bah en fait ti
j'ai envie de pisser bah du coup je vais
faire ça et donc tu pisses dans ta
bouteille et là c'est pas la pisse du
matin tu vois qui est un peu concentré
ou même après avoir bu quelques bières
c'est une urine qui est marron orange
qui a un goût relativement dernier filt
à desin ouais et puis là c'est très
c'est très très fort en terme d'odeur
c'est très très fort tu scoues le truc
tu dis is ça va être compliqué et tu
mets ça dans la bouche tu fais waouh
allez tuaval et je me souviendrais
toujours c'est descendu et c'est remonté
d'un coup j'ai refermé la bouche voilà
là c'est bon je l'ai et ça m'a permis de
regagner le prochain point il y avait un
point à presque 20 km plus loin où j'ai
pu avoir un un point d'eau pour me pour
me réhydrater tout doucement et repartir
le lendemain que c'est ce que je dis
souvent aux stagiaires je leur dis si
vous arrivez à cette à ce point-là de
devoir boire votre urine vous savez qu'à
moment donné vous allez plus avoir d'eau
et vous allez devoir boire votre urine
et bien essayez d'anticiper gardez
toujours un peu d'eau mais vraiment une
un fond d'eau pour le mélanger non pour
se rincer la bouche ah pour se rincer
derrière pour le goû c'est dégueulasse
de rester avec un gû de PCE dans la
bouche toute la journée c'est là où
l'eau c'est devenu un combat pour toi
ouais c'est ça le le le la quête de
l'eau et de se dire je vais dédier la
suite de mes aventures sur la la notion
de l'eau cétait à ce moment-là c'était
vraiment de se dire j'ai failli crever
en plein milieu du désert peut-être que
ça peut arriver à d'autres personnes
mais c'est un combat qu'ils ont au côé
qutiiden donc je vais essayer d'éveiller
les consciences et de faire prendre
encore plus conscience en tout cas à la
plupart des gens précieux que c'est que
l'eau est un liquide très précieux et
que certes on en a partout sur terre
c'est de plus en plus inégal et puis
elle est répartie depuis quelques années
un peu bizarrement avec le réchauffement
climatique et que la qualité de l'eau
diminue malheureusement d'année en année
et que si on veut poursuivre et
continuer à avoir une belle existence
sur terre et bien faut préserver ce bien
très très précieux comment ça s'est
passé ta rencontre avec les arorigènes
la rencontre avec aborigènes était très
particulière parce que on ressent cette
pression de l'homme blanc de
l'Australien donc vraiment le blanc qui
arrivé en 1789 avec le capitaine James
Cook tu ressens vraiment la différence
entre les aboriggènes et les blancs ils
sont parqués j'allais dire même si le
mot est quand même très fort mais dans
des communautés on les a mis entre eux
ils sont un peu éloignés des des grandes
villes ça a été très dur au tout début
parce que tu arrives dans une communauté
tu as vraiment l'impression que c'est le
Far West il y a rien et je me suis
rapproché on va dire du centre
névralgique le truc le plus important de
la communauté c'està dire la
superpérette et je me suis posé sur le
banc en plein milieu du désert à côté de
la superette et j'ai attendu en plein
caniard et j'ai vu une voiture passer
une deuxième et c'était vraiment un peu
comme dans le ghetto il baissait la
fenêtre is un repérage regardait comme
ça et je fais oh la vache c'est chaud et
il partait et ça a duré plusieurs
dizaines de minutes et à un moment donné
il y en a un qui s'arrêtait qui est
descendu il est venu me voir il m'a
demandé qu'est-ce que je faisais là qui
j'étais et je suis bah moi je suis parti
de Melbourne en courant et je vais
jusqu'à Darwin voilà et je suis français
et on dit ah it's you il est parti je
super l'introduction et il s'est
barré et euh quelques dizaines de
minutes après toute toute la communauté
est arrivé ils sont venus un par un
comme ça et ils m' dit ah mais on
Tattend
prévenz les copains moi j'étais pas au
courant donc ça a été très dur au début
et puis tout doucement j'ai réussi à
prendre mes marques et pour pouvoir
rentrer facilement en contact avec eux
et bien je passais plus facilement par
le biais des enfants parce que les
enfants s'ouvrent plus facilement aux
étranger exactement et le fait de
pouvoir parler avec eux et bien
j'arrivais plus facilement à entrer en
contact avec les parents et encore une
fois c'est le même principe c'est de
montrer que tu es pas tu tu viens pas en
tant que Conquérent tu viens pas prendre
tu viens juste juste partager du temps
euh apprendre de leur culture et et les
respecter et après l'autre partie qui
est très importante et bien c'est le
temps le temps fait que si tu viens et
que tu veux juste passer une journée
avec eux vite vite vite vite prendre des
photos et partir mais on aurait la même
problématique tu tu es en plein milieu
de la campagne chez toi et tu as des
gens qui arrivent et ils veulent juste
prendre des photos et partir mais tu as
pas envie de leur parler cassez-vous
vous avez rien à faire ici alors que si
tu as des gens qui viennent prennent le
temps de comprendre ce que tu fais là
pourquoi tu es là et quel est l' tes
objectifs de vie et bien tout d'un coup
tu vas forcément te livrer plus
facilement et c'est ce que c'est ce que
j'ai fait dans les deux communautés je
suis resté en tout 25 jours et j'ai eu
cette chance de pouvoir passer du temps
avec eux ils m'ont ils m'ont fait rire
on mangit de la queue de kangourou et et
forcément il donne la partie la plus
éloignée de du début de la queue de
kangourou qui est un truc très
gélatineux qui est dégueulasse à et moi
je faisais semblant de m'chouiller et
hop tu donnis au chien tout ça jeis oh
là là mon Dieu faut pas qu' le voit et
c'est c'est juste très drôle temp visité
et ouais un peu ouais et tu te rends
compte que dans les communautés euh où
il y a où on est vraiment très loin de
de la civilisation que l'on connaît nous
ce sont les femmes qui cont enfin qui
font tout dans les communautés les
hommes contrôlent les communautés c'est
les hommes qui qui qui déterminent et
qui donnent vraiment qui donnent les
ordres mais ce sont les femmes qui font
tout c'est les femmes qui s'occupent de
l'éducation c'est les femmes qui
s'occupent de la nourriture c'est les
femmes qui gèrent tout donc si tu
arrives à entrer en contact avec les
femmes ce qui est plus difficile parce
qu'elles sont plus réservées mais une
fois que c'est fait ben tu apprends
énormément pour parler aussi de ta
traversé du Mekong ça c'était ta
deuxième aventure c'est ça je dis pas de
bêtises donc du Tibet jusqu'au Vietnam
pendant 6 mois soit 4400 km c'est
correct ouais exactement l'Australie on
avait bien compris tu était allé une
frustration de pas vraiment avoir
rencontré les personnes c'est ça ça te
donne ton élan de départ ou ta racine de
motivation pourquoi là le Mekong Mekong
j'avais rencontré euh j'avais visité
l'Asie du Sud-Est et j'avais été sur le
Mekong en 2000 2009 euh à la suite de
l'Australie de mon voyage en Australie
donc av on avait été en Asie du Sud-Est
et j'avais beaucoup apprécié la
population et les gens et euh et en
cherchant pas mal d'infos sur le meékong
on se rend compte que c'est un fleuve
qui est très stratégique positionné en
Asie du Sud-Est qui commence par la
Chine donc un pays qui est pas forcément
le plus simple en terme de d'échange de
négociation qui se termine directement
au Vietnam qui irgue six pays donc des
problématiques géopolitiques
socio-culturelles environnemental
écologique et cetera et en regardant
tout le tracé et bien je trouvais que
c'était un un un beau moyen d'entrer en
communication différemment avec la
population et de comprendre et bien tous
les enjeux liés à l'eau parce que je
l'avais vécu en Australie avec le manque
d'eau et donc je voulais voir comment
les gens se nourrissaient au bord du
Mekong est-ce qu'ils allaient
directement puiser l'eau du fleuve pour
se nourrir ou est-ce que ils allaient en
superet est-ce qu'ils captaient l'eau
sur des sources en hauteur et cetera
cétait la composante eau qui s'était
rajouter et d'ailleurs elle se rajoute
tellement que là tu vas pas le faire en
courant le long du Mekong tuas le faire
en nageant c'est ça au tout début
c'était de la nage pure je voulais nager
vraiment en Craw et j'ai rencontré un
club de nage en N viive à isoudin dans
dans l'Indre en 36 et en discutant avec
les les formateurs on était un soir ils
avaient entraînement il y en a pas un
seul qui s'entraînit on a dit discuter
toute la soirée et on dit mais tu sais
reméy si tu le fais vraiment à la nage
pure tu vas faire quelques centaines de
mètres avant de finir noyer et je
trouvais que ça faisait plutôt court sur
4400 km pour raconter une histoire tu
vois tu vois je dis ça serait pas le but
c'était de rencontrer les gens et pas de
mourir tout de suite et ils m'ont dit
bah nous on pratique un sport qui
s'appelle l'hydros speed ok ok ça a
l'air fun dit viens samedi on fait un
entraînement sur un bassin d'eau vif
fermé donc avec des pompes et cetera
comme ça tu vas voir un peu ce que c'est
et j'ai trouvé ça tellement bien j'ai
dit mais c'est ça en fait je vais le
faire en hydrosped donc c'est un
flotteur en mousse on met les mains à
l'intérieur avec des palmes et puis une
combinaison gilet sauvetage et
l'avantage c'est qu'on a la tête hors de
l'eau en fait on descend les torrents
exactement comme si on utilisait un
kayak sauf qu'on est à moitié voilà on
est à moitié immergé dans l'eau un peu
comme une grenouille et je trouvais que
c'était un bon moyen d'entrer en contact
avec la population parce que en ayant la
tête dans l'eau en agant et bien c'est
difficile d'entrer en contact avec les
gens alors que là ben j'étais
toujoursêre hors de l'eau donc je
pouvais leur faire des grands coucous et
pour eux c'était particulier de voir un
mec habillé en grenouille en jaune et
bleu qui descendait le mécong ils
avaient jamais vu ça donc beaucoup
venaient me demander de sortir de l'eau
viens viens viens pour me poser des
questions parce que il comprenaient pas
ce que c'était que personne fait ça en
fait personne descend le Mékong avec un
hydrosped c'est quoi qui a été le plus
difficile sur sur cette partie aquatique
avec le mécong de parler avec les gens
on en revient encore une fois sur de la
communication ça c'était très difficile
d'être avec eux et de devoir parler et
de trouver les mots justes parce que tu
commences en Chine ensuite tu fais entre
la Birmanie et le Laos après un peu de
Thaïlande tu revient au Laos après il y
a le Cambodge le Vietnam et chaque pays
a sa langue chaque chaque pays a sa
façon d'écrire et la plupart des endroit
où je pouvais me retrouver la beaucoup
de personnes ne savaient ni lire ni
écrire donc tu te retrouves à devoir
essayer en dessinant enfin j'ai jamais
autant de dessiner de ma vie sur le sol
avec du charbon de bois quoi pour
essayer de faire comprendre ce que je
voulais et des phrases toutes simples
de leur demander par exemple je pars de
ce point-là où il y a un barrage pour
aller jusqu'à ce prochain barrage entre
les deux points là combien de kilomètres
ça la phrase ça ça nous a pris à peu
près 10 secondes pour que je te la dise
et que tu la comprennes mais comment tu
fais pour t'exprimer quand tu parles pas
la langue pour leur faire comprendre
entre ces deux points quelle est la
distance quel est le nombre de
kilomètres mais des fois il me fallait
deux TR jours pour qu'il y en un qui
comprenne donc je dessinais je faisais
un barrage hydroélectrique je
mais il est quand même bien fait mon
barrage et tout là je faisais panneau
électrique comme ça avec une petite
ampoule je c'est pour l'électricité et
tout non toujours pas bon c'est tombé et
le lendemain j'ai rencontré d'autres
gens et je recommençais et un jour il y
en a un qui me dit ah prends la il prend
le charbon de bois et il écrit 42 je
fais ah il a peut-être compris après je
prenais pas ça pour argent content ok cé
un indice potentiel voilà il a dit 42
après ils sont pas tous des GPS
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire 42 est-ce que
c'est 42 minutes donc j'avais pas mais
j'avais au moins quelque chose d'
ok bon ça je vais pouvoir m'appuyer
là-dessus et voir par la suite donc ça
c'était très très dur et tu as et il
faut être capable
de d'accepter le fait que on parle pas
la même langue
et on en revient à ce que je disais avec
les aborigènes c'est faut pas faut pas
paraître grand faut pas paraître méchant
faut pas être là en conquérant et tu as
et tu viens de te faire 15 heur de
palmage dans la journée donc tu as les
gambes en feu tu es fatigué tu en peux
plus tu as faim tu as soif mais les gens
eux ils veulent avoir des réponses à
leur questions et il faut prendre le
temps de leur répondre et des fois on
passait des soirées je sais pas jusqu'à
2h 3h du matin où tu dois répondre à des
questions tuen peux plus ils te servent
de l'alcool de riz ils te servent de la
bière chaude dégueulasse tu dis mais
j'en peux plus j'ai aucune envie c'est
de dormir mais comment tu vas leur faire
comprendre sans les blesser de le leur
dire faut que j'aille dormir tu parce
que demain matin moi à 5h30 je me lève
et je repars nager mais eux ils sont
moqué c'était pas leur tu es l'événement
exactement l'événement c'était vraiment
le cas tuas le village qui débarque
c'est que tu étais jamais tout seul il y
a toujours du monde qui vient pour
savoir qui tu es ce que tu fais et
cetera et ça c'était très dur au
cotidien et j'avais besoin par moment de
m'éloigner de trouver des endroits très
reculés pour me cacher de la population
pour pas qu'il vienneent j'ai dormi une
fois dans les marécages au milieu de nu
part avec des ras et des serpents je
suis là s y en a un qui vient me voir
c'est vraiment parce qu'il est il est
déterminé quoi et tu dors et au moins tu
étais j'avais vraiment cette sensation
d'être seul et d'avoir une nuit
reposante sans avoir à devoir parler à
la population et de raconter de raconter
parce que c'est pas tu le fais une fois
et la prochaine fois c'est la semaine
d'après c'est tous les jours pendant 6
mois il faut raconter ce que tu fais tu
t'attendais aussi à la à cette toxicité
de l'eau et aux impacts qu'elle pourrait
avoir parfois sur toi euh j'ai eu des
pieds complètement al déformés pas
visuellement ou ils étaient complètement
mais ils avaient grossi en volume et
puis je m'arrachais complètement la peau
j'avais des des des plaques partout au
niveau des pied j'avais un pied en tout
cas qui était qui avait vraiment doublé
de volume et je j'utilisais qu'une seule
palme pour avancer parce que j'en
pouvais plus ça me brûlait trop donc et
ça je l'ai ressenti mais c'est pas
uniquement lié à la qualité de l'eau il
y avait un mix de tout il y avait
l'effort depuis temp temp de mois donc
j'avais ce mix de tout ça et
effectivement plus j'avançais vers le
bas du Mekong et plus tu avais une une
qualité d'eau qui diminuit il y avait
d'autres dangers aussi tu as eu un coup
de foudre j'ai eu un alors j'ai eu de la
foudre
en plein milieu du en plein milieu du du
Mekong où là tu te sens très petit et je
suis sorti sur un bateau qui était
fabriqué en bois avec une structure
métallique et j'avais la main qui était
à quelques dizaines centimètres de la
structure métallique et l'éclair quand
il est tombé à 200 300 m du bateau c'est
passé à travers la structure et j'ai eu
la main paralysée pendant 10 secondes
300 m plus tard ouais donc tu vois les
que les éléments se déchaînent tu vois
que il faut être faut être humble envers
la nature aussi on a j'ai eu des monté
des eau très très violentes sur le
meékong parce que il pleuvait sur une
partie haute d'ailleurs c'est ce que
j'ai j'enseigne à mes stagièr je leur
dis ne dormez jamais dans les parties
basses à côté d'une rivière à un ou 2 m
d'une rivière dormez toujours un peu
plus loin parce que c'est pas parce
qu'il fait grand beau là où est-ce que
vous êtes que dans l'heure ou dans les 2
heures qui suivent vous allez avoir 4 m
de flotte il peut très bien pleuvoir en
amont et c'est catastrophique donc c'est
là où tu te rends compte de la puissance
de l'eau et des éléments et qu'il faut
être humble et respecte tu et de te dire
de toute manière je peux pas faire plus
que la nature mais je peux juste essayer
de la comprendre et à un moment donné de
la respecter est-ce que tu es en train
de préparer une aventure ou est-ce que
tu es encore plutôt dans une phase de
restitution en ce moment alors j'ai fini
ma 4e aventure au mois de juin j'ai
traverser la Méditerranée à la nage en
en totale autonomie et presque sans
assistance je dis bien presque parce que
j'ai pas pu le faire sans assistance les
conditions étaient trop compliquées donc
c VI Monaco et là on est en train de
travailler justement sur la restitution
avec le film de cette aventure qui
devrait sortir prochainement et qui sera
à mon avis un joli bijou parce qu'on a
fait des très très belles photos et très
belles vidéos on a beaucoup de chance
nous de l'autre côté parce que tu
documentes énormément tu sais bien faire
ces restitutions là donc j'essaie en
tout cas de de l'apporter pour que les
gens puissent le voir on a tous envie de
partir à l'aventure maintenant mais je
t'attends viens viens sur franchement
venez avec toute l'équipe sur un stage
de survie ça grand plaisir cette chaise
se baisse il disparaî bien il est plus
là il plus là merci merci beaucoup merci
merci à Remy Camu pour sa générosité
c'était passionnant si vous voulez lire
son livre je vous le mets dans la
description c'est ça qui m'a donné envie
de l'inviter il est vraiment passionnant
et je vous mets rappelez-vous toutes les
dates que vous voyez apparaître c'est
mon spectacle en tourné humour
mentalisme et sciance dans la
description à très bientôt Ciao